You famously worked in publishing. Oh yes. I did. Yes just for a little while. What did you do in publishing? I have no idea
How long did you do it for? This was in preparation for Bridget Jones, yeah, how long how long did you do it for? Ah, let's see
I went over in January. We started filming after Easter, so- couple of months. Yeah, good good few months
Yeah, so, I mean you must have done something. Well, yeah, I did I got the coffee
I made the coffee
I had to you know, cut anything out of you know
The local periodicals or that are about the authors that the publishing company represented
So I do that and then file them away and I had to organize the the book launches and things like that
Yeah, well and who do they say you were they said that I was a Bridget Cavendish?
So a relative of the gentleman who was the owner of the publishers which explained why I got the job with absolutely no skills whatsoever